oh chloe you have the biggest heart it's
so big it has room for tristan and all
of his side pieces oh
and chris chris you're not one of my
sisters that's not a joke i just thought
i'd remind you
kim kardashian totally crushed her
saturday night live monologue back in
october
but now thanks to the famous family's
new hulu show the kardashians fans are
getting to hear one of the jokes that
didn't make it and it is good you have a
real insight into what the girls are
doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes the
41 year old skim's founder tested a few
of her jokes on her pal amy schumer just
days before her appearance on the sketch
comedy show including one about kim's
sister chloe and her ex tristan thompson
oh chloe you have the biggest heart it's
so big it has room for tristan and all
of his side pieces oh
and chris chris you're not one of my
sisters that's not a joke i just thought
i'd remind you while the 37 year old
good american founder and the nba star
were together he was caught in several
cheating scandals including one with
chloe's sister kylie jenner's former
bestie jordan woods of course i'm sorry
and apologetic as much as i can be and
another when she was pregnant with their
daughter true when i was nine months
pregnant
when you cheated on me
if i wasn't pregnant i would have picked
you up so i just didn't want to break my
nails before delivery leading up to the
show's premiere chloe told et she
wouldn't hold back when it came to
dishing on all that drama at least for
now it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives especially the
older ones we've been doing this for so
long but back to kim on snl hey guys
it's so great to be here hosting
saturday night live i know i'm surprised
to see me here too
when they asked i was like you want me
to host why i haven't had a movie
premiere in a really long time
actually i've only had that one movie
come out and no one even told me it was
premiering it must have slipped my mom's
mind wait what was the movie
my sex tape
thank you yeah thank you great
the 40 year old comedian wasn't really
feeling kim's throwback sex tape joke i
think i just wouldn't do any sex tape
stuff well kim she used it anyway i
haven't had a movie premiere in a really
long time
i mean actually i only had that one
movie come out and no one told me it was
even premiering but one of amy's jokes
did make it to air you could be like
because i don't know if you guys know
this but i don't need the exposure from
this show like you know
like i'm not hoping to get discovered
tonight
yeah if anything you know usually i'm i
have 250 million followers if anything
tonight i just wanted some intimacy with
some close friends yes
i'm so used to having 360 million
followers watching my every move i mean
how many people watch snl like 10
million so tonight
tonight is just a chill intimate night
for me
and last week amy gushed over her
friend's performance during a chat with
howard stern i mean she went after her
family in that monologue i mean she's an
amazing person like think about what
she's accomplished you know
[Music]